They just said that,
but I mean,
how many rape jokes,
like overall,
do you have
many times I say the rape or is it no bits.
Yeah.
I mean really just that one raped.
It's with long bit though.
So it's a lot of jokes within it and I'm being raped in the joke most of the
time.
Okay.
So that's,
you know,
think that's why a guy being it helps.
But I,
you know,
I don't want,
I don't want to ruin the bid either,
but I think you have to.
Um,
I,
I respect the fact that people can be triggered,
but it's a very strange thing to me because for me,
I'm always trying to find something really funny from this dark shit,
right?
Whether it's a personal experience or whatever it is.
And the way we're looking at as comics is we're trying to find something really
positive out of something really shitty.
And then you have like a movie,
which is just,
there may be so fucked up seem,
there's nothing.
It's,
I mean,
look,
it's,
it's a positive piece of content.
Tag it to one person talking.
Yeah.
It's a scene.
You're watching people act out a scene.
You're right.
There's something very personal about one person talking.
That's why this is,
I mean it's not,
this is how some people would look at it like you should talk about things that
you really care about while you're doing that because you only have a certain
amount of time to do it,
you know?
And some sometimes,
yeah,
sometimes sometimes you,
you have a bit,
it's just not worth it.
You know,
like the way people react to it,
just like,
yeah.
Even though you have a point,
it's like even working this bit out,
people are getting so upset.
It's almost not worth it.
No,
it has to be a net positive.
The crowd has to be laughing,
so there's no,
you know,
I'm okay.
I will defend somebody.
Right.
To tell a shitty joke.
You know what I'm saying?
But at the same time,
I understand if as a performer you have to gauge the audience and put your
finger in the air and go,
okay,
which way is the wind blowing right now?
The reality is you can't say things you used to say.
You can't say faggot onstage anymore in a crowd in New York or la.
You can't say that word.
The crowd will tighten up and shut down.
You'll ruin the rest of whatever that joke is.
So it's,
it's obviously,
I haven't seen Dia's recently.
Maybe they say pack a lunch.
Oh,
he's awesome.
He'll say whatever he wants.
But I got a point.
I,
you know,
I have a joke about,
my,
uh,
my dog and I used to say my faggot dog because he's looking at another male dogs
asshole on the joke.
And uh,
and people would shut down at that word and it's really two months with the New
York in La.
That's where the biggest fat gets live.
Um,
the rest of the country is cool.
If you go anywhere else,
they don't really give a shit about where it's like that.
But in New York and La,
it's become a particularly hard thing to,
you know,
there's certain words and certain things.
It's not even the content necessarily,
it's just those words that sort of set people's sensors off.
Well,
there's always going to be a bunch of words like that.
What's really interesting is what does happen when you stop people from saying
it,
cause it's Kinda counterintuitive because those words become these forbidden
words.
Just give him more power.
They,
there's so much more power if you don't send,
I don't just,
I just don't think you ever get to tell people that you can't say certain words.
They used to be able to say all the time,
you know,
I mean the idea behind those words is still the same.
Like if you say to someone you shouldn't say retarded anymore,
even though that used to be like a term that they would use for things being
slower,
like their growth being slower,
their growth was retarded.
But now if you even use it as a technical term,
like in,
in the growth was retarded.
People get upset at you don't use that anymore.
Now that's a forbidden sound.
Even if it doesn't mean what they think it means.
We're talking about a person with down syndrome.
They don't like hearing the r word.
The yeah.
You,
you talked about in your special,
I thought it was a great bed where you're like,
just these sounds from your face,
like what do we,
what are we doing?
You know,
it's just the,
you're making these different sounds with your mouth,
so you're,
yeah.
It's just sounds,
well,
it's a,
it's a buy product of speech being shitty way to really clearly convey intent.
And that's why when someone is good at speaking their mind,
we kind of get,
uh,
we get a real sense of,
we enjoy it.
Someone's good at speaking their mind,
but if someone's sucks at speaking their mind,
you know,
if they're,
if they're they're clunky at it,
then it's not enjoyable.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I agree.
Um,
and there's too many people that there's no barrier of entry and we're exposed
to a lot of horseshit very quickly now.
Whereas like,
I think back in the day,
comedians had time to grow in a club.
You know,
you look at Bob Saget,
right?
Bob Saget was like a dirty fucking filthy comic who ended up getting on the
cleanest television show ever.
Right.
The Dad,
you know,
Danny Tanner was,
but then you,
if there was cell phones out back then,
he would have never gotten that Gig.
Well,
I think he stopped doing standup for a long time because that too,
right?
Yeah.
I think that'll take,
you didn't stand up while he was doing that show.
I might be wrong,
but if he did do it,
maybe did let go and abridged,
uh,
you know,
PG 13 version or something.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't know,
man.
It's,
is it worth it?
He knows it works.
It censoring telling me,
I think one day it seems like the more time goes on,
the more words they're sneaking into network television.
You hear like shit every now and then I think,
I think you're allowed to say shit and asshole on a network show now.
Yeah.
There was like a big episode once on something.
You say shit in my asshole though.
No,
you can't say that.
Yeah.
It's just too,
you can call somebody a dick,
but you can refer to your deck.
That's the idea,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You can call someone a pussy.
I think even too,
which is weird.
You know that one's on the way out.
Yeah.
That's one that's become a thing where you're feminizing a man and now that's
offensive to women and fuck you,
bitch.
Now I'm calling my buddy a pussy and you get to take the offense on that.
That's some crazy woman shit that's actually right there.
That's how crazy women are.
It's not how crazy women are.
It's how crazy some women are.
It's like,
like some men are fucking crazy too.
You're just dealing with a giant number of people,
but if people find a little thing where they can pick on it and go after it like
that.
Yeah.
I Dunno.
I have none.
There's nothing.
There's no,
it's very funny to me.
There's no words feminizing that could possibly offend me.
That could ever,
right.